you tweeted that it's interesting to
ponder that if Oort clouds are ever
mined by the systems of alien
civilizations mining equipment from
billions of years ago could be in our
Oort cloud since the Oort clouds are
they they extend really really really
really far outside the the actual star
yeah that so you know mining equipment
just a basic boring mining equipment out
there I don't know if there's something
interesting to say about or claws
themselves that that are interesting to
you and about possible
non-shiny uh light emitting uh mining
equipment from Alien civilization yeah I
mean that thought I mean that's kind of
the beauty of the field of tender
signatures and looking for life is
you can find inspiration and
intellectual joy in just the smallest
little thing that starts a whole thread
of building upon it and wondering about
the implications and so in this case I
was just really struck by we couldn't
mentioned this a little bit earlier the
idea that stars are not static we tend
to think of the Galaxy as having stars
in a certain location from the center of
the Galaxy and they kind of live there
but in truth the stars are not only
orbiting around the center of the Galaxy
but those orbits are themselves changing
over time they're processing and so in
fact the orbits look more like a
spirograph if you've ever done those as
a kid it kind of whirl around and Trace
out all sorts of strange patterns and so
the Stars intersect with one another and
so the current closest star to us is
Proxima Centauri which is about 4.2
light years away but it will not always
be the closest star and over millions of
years it will be supplanted by other
stars in fact either will come even
closer than proximo within just a couple
of light years and that's been happening
not just we can project that will happen
over the next few million years but
that's been happening presumably
throughout the entire history of the
Galaxy for billions of years and so if
you went back in time it you know it
would have been all sorts of different
nearest Stars right different stages of
the Earth's history and those stars are
so close that they're all clouds do
intermix with one another so the orc
card can extend out to even a light year
or two around the earth there's some
debate about exactly where it ends it
probably doesn't really have a
definitive end but kind of more just
kind of pieces out more and more and
more as you go further away for people
who don't know nor Cloud I don't know
what the technical definition is but a
bunch of rocks that kind of no objects
that orbit the the star and they can
extend really really great because these
are objects that probably uh mostly icy
Rich they were probably formed fairly
similar distances to Jupiter and Saturn
but we're scattered out through the
interactions of those giant planets we
see a circular disk of objects around us
which kind of looks like the asteroid
belt but just for the way called the
Kuiper belt and then further beyond that
you get the all clout and the all cloud
is not in a disk it's just a sphere it
kind of surrounds Us in all directions
so these are objects that were scattered
out through three-dimensionally in all
different directions
and so those objects are potentially
resources for us especially if you were
planning to do an Interstellar mission
one day you might want to mine the water
that's embedded within those and use
that as either oxygen or a fuel for your
rocket and so it's quite possible
there's also some rare earth metals and
things like that as well but it's quite
possible that a civilization might use
all Cloud objects as a jumping off point
um or or in the Kuiper belt you have
things like planet nine evens that's
there might even be objects Beyond in
the Oort cloud which are actually
planet-like that we just cannot detect
these objects are very very faint so
that's why they're so hard to see I mean
even planet nine is hypothesized to
exist but we've not been able to confirm
its existence because it's at something
like a thousand a u away from us a
thousand times the distance of the Earth
from the Sun and so even though it's
probably larger than the earth the
amount of light it reflects from the sun
the sun is what just looks like a star
at that point so far away from it that
it barely reflects anything back it's
extremely difficult to detect so there's
all sorts of Wonders that may be lurking
out in the outer solar system
and so this has leads you to wonder
um
you know in the Oort cloud
that all Cloud must have intermixed with
other raw clouds in the past and so what
fraction of the hot cloud is truly
belongs to us belongs to the what was
scattered from Jupiter and Saturn what
fraction of it could in fact be uh
Interstellar visitors and of course
we've got excited about this recently
because of omomoa they seem to start an
asteroid which seemed to be at the time
the first evidence of an instiller
object but when you think about the all
Cloud into mixing
um it may be that a large fraction of
comets comets are seeded from the Oort
cloud that eventually come in some of
those comets May indeed have been
Interstellar in the first place that we
just didn't know about through this
process
um there even is an example I can't
remember the name there's an example of
a comment that has a very peculiar
special signature that has been
hypothesized to have actually been an
Interstellar visitor but one that was
essentially sourced through this awk
Cloud mixing and so this is kind of
intriguing
um
and also you know the outer solar system
is just such a it's like the bottom of
the ocean we know so little about what's
on the bottom of our own plants ocean
and we know next to nothing about
watching the outskirts of our own solar
system it's all Darkness yeah so like
that that's one of the things is to
understand the phenomena we need light
and we need to see how light interacts
with it or it would light emanates from
it
but most of our universe is Darkness so
it's
there could be a lot of interesting
stuff I mean this is where your interest
is with the with the cool worlds and the
interesting stuff lurks in the darkness
right basically all of us you know 400
years of astronomy are only window into
the universe has been light and that has
only changed quite recently with the
discovery of gravitational waves that's
now a new window and hopefully uh well
to some degree I guess solar neutrinos
we've been detecting from art but they
come from the certain Interstellar space
but we may be able to soon detect
neutrino messages as even been
hypothesized as a way of communicating
between civilizations as well or just do
neutrino telescopes to study the
universe and so there's a growing
interest in what we'd call
multi-messenger astronomy now so not
just messages from light but messages
from these but the physical
packets of information that are coming
our way but when it comes to the outer
Solar System Light really is our only
window there's two there's two ways of
doing that one is you detect the light
from the all Cloud object itself which
as I just said is very very difficult
there's another trick which we do in the
Kuiper belt especially and that's called
an occultation and so sometimes those
objects will just pass in front of a
distant star just coincidentally these
are very very brief moments they last
for less than a second and so you have
to have a very fast camera to detect
them which conventionally astronomers
don't usually build fast cameras most of
the phenomena we observe occurs on hours
minutes stays even but now we're
developing cameras which can take you
know thousands of images per second and
yet do it at the kind of astronomical
Fidelity that we that we need for this
kind of precise measurement and so you
can see these these very fast dips you
even get these kind of diffraction
patterns that come around which are
really cool to look at and that's I kind
of love it because it's almost like
passive radar your you have these
pinpricks of light imagine that you live
in a giant black sphere but there's
these little pinholes that have been
poked and through those pinholes almost
laser light is shining through and
inside this black sphere there are
unknown things wandering around drifting
around that we are trying to discover
and sometimes they will pass in front of
those little Pencil Thin laser beams and
block something out and so we can tell
that it's there and it's not an active
radar because we didn't actually you
know beam anything out and get a
reflection off which is what the sun
does the Sun's light comes off and it
comes back that's more like an active
radar system there's more like a passive
radar system where we are just listening
very intently and so
um I'm kind of so fascinated by that the
idea that we could map out the rich
architecture of the outer solar system
just by doing something that we could
have done potentially for a long time
okay which is just listening in the
right way just just tuning Our
instrumentation to the correct way of of
not listening but viewing the universe
to catch those objects yeah that means
it's really fascinating it seems almost
obvious that your efforts when projected
out in over like 100 200 years will have
a really good map through even methods
that basically Transit timing high
resolution Transit timing but basically
the planetary and the uh the planet
satellite movements that of all the
different star systems out there yeah
and it could revolutionize the way we
think about the solar system I mean that
revolution has happened several times in
the past when we discovered Vesta in the
19th century
um that was I think the the seventh
planet for a while or the eighth planet
when it was first discovered and then we
discovered Ceres and there was a bunch
of asteroid objects Janus and so for a
while the textbooks had
um there was something like 13 planets
in the solar system and then they and
then that was just a new capability that
was emerging to detach those small
objects and then we ripped that up and
said no no we're gonna change the
definition of a planet and then the same
thing happened when we started looking
the outer skirts of the solar system
again we found Eris we found sedna these
objects which resembled Pluto and the
more and more of them we found make make
and eventually we again had to rethink
the way we even contextualize what a
planet is and what the nature of the
outer solar system is so regardless as
to what you think about the debate about
whether Pluto should be demoted or not
which I know often invokes a lot of
strong feelings it is an incredible
achievement that we were able to
transform our view of the solar system
in a matter of years just by basically
you know charge coupled devices the
things that's in in cameras
um though the invention of that device
allowed us to detect objects which were
much further away much fainter and
revealed all of this stuff that was
there all along and so it that's the
beauty of astronomy that's just
uh so much to discover and even in our
own backyard